it's funny how foreigners
ask me the same questions when they
first meet me
questions like wow you're from mongolia
so do you ride horses to go to work
do you know what coke is or
do you have chocolates in mongolia
and if i want to have fun with it
i say things like oh my god i've never
heard any of those before
what are coke and chocolates can you
tell me more about them
it always works and we have a good laugh
about it too
in reality our capital city olambatar
is very urban we have commercial
buildings brand name hotels
and beautiful art spaces too but
all too often foreigners fixate
on what mongolia lacks they look at our
massive
untouched landscape traditional nomadic
lifestyles
and see it as a sign of poverty
and i disagree in fact i think there's a
lot we can learn from
ancient mongolian nomads that will help
us survive in the years
and decades to come this is a picture of
me playing
mongolia's most celebrated traditional
instrument murohur
or horsehead fiddle i started playing
the instrument when i was only nine
and by 11 i was traveling the world
representing mongolia at international
festivals
living and studying in places like japan
china finland germany and sweden
but then suddenly when i was 21
i lost my loving mother and just
two years later i lost my father
as an only child i was devastated
and lonely at the time the only thing i
had left was my country
so i decided to move home
when i was lost with sorrow my country
gave me a feeling of safety
and belonging i imagined the eternal
blue sky of mongolia as my father
and the unsuch gorgeous landscape is my
mother
having lived and developed countries for
over a decade
i became very distant from the nomadic
lifestyles
so i wanted to reconnect and experience
it for myself
i often journeyed away from the city
toward my grandparents provinces
in rural mongolia to see where my
parents
and i came from and better understand my
own identity
growing up i'd always heard stories
about how mongolian nomads
were the most hospitable people on earth
and i wanted to see with my own eyes
whether they really
fit and give shelter to a stranger
so i sat up to the countryside driving
along dirt roads for
hours what's incredible about mongolian
nomads
is that the neighbors are often 40
kilometers apart
and there's no private land ownership of
pasture land in mongolia
in a way mongolian nomads have the
complete freedom
moving about the gorgeous landscape as
they wish eventually
i spotted two humble yards and i pulled
over
yours or gear are traditional mongolian
dwelling
they're made from 100 natural material
a wooden frame and floor leather rope
and thick blankets
made from felted sheep's wool and it
takes about only three to four hours to
assemble
or disassemble and keeps them warm
through the minus 50 degrees celsius
winters
outside the earth the kids were playing
with sheeps and goats
and as i greeted them their parents
welcomed me inside
the wife poured me nice warm milk tea
and the husband offered me food that i
had already prepared on the table
after some casual chit chat the husband
politely asked my purpose
so i replied bluntly that i was just
traveling and exploring my grandparents
roots
and that i needed a place to stay as the
sun was setting
and guess what he said i could stay as
long as i needed to
on one condition he asked if i would
play the muranghor
our traditional mongolian horsehead
fiddle
in my head i couldn't believe it was
coming true
and the horse said fiddle is like a
ticket
when mongolians find out that you can
play murohur
you're instantly respected they say
it's two strings express all the events
of the world
i ended up staying with them for nine
days
and they didn't even ask me to leave i
think if i tried to stay there for two
months they would have fled me
and here's the thing before i met them
i assumed that mongolian nomads were
hospitable
out of kindness like anybody else but
then
i realized it was more than that it was
about surviving
as a community because nomads
live in extremely remote areas they are
completely at the mercy of nature
heavy snowfall a sudden flood
or a raging storm can devastate the
nomadic family
today it's a stranger who needs help
but tomorrow it could be you
that's why they look out for each other
and welcome anyone
in need of help this really touched my
heart
because i feel like we humans are
becoming more and more selfish
staying with the truly nomadic family
awakened me
it was nothing like i've ever seen in
developed countries
the wife of the family showed me how
they produce organic
dairy products from scratch like white
cheese yogurt etsy
and even a traditional vodka made from
cow milk
and every tool they use is made from the
natural material by hand
and inside the youth we burned dried cow
dung
to stay warm instead of using fuel
everything stood in sharp contrast to my
city life filled with plastic and steel
and this was a five census experience to
me
a completely different form of
sophistication
the more i traveled across remote and
rural destinations in mongolia
the more i understood how ancient
nomadic lifestyle
was powered by mother nature nomadic
life
is truly zero waste
over the course of six years i visited
more than 20 families
and my experience was always the same
they invited me in offered me food and
gave me a place to stay if i needed
i was surprised by how little they owned
at first i thought it was because they
move about four times a year
okay that's a very simple logic to
understand you only carry what you need
but then i learned there's a deeper
philosophy behind
it historically nomads believed
that we are only passing through this
life the people come and live naked
so they believe that there's no point in
building
anything that destroys nature or
in being greedy for materialistic things
when your life expectancy is
only less than 100 years instead
they invest in tradition heritage
history
and pass it from generation to
generation
this ancient nomadic philosophy made me
realize
that i should think bigger and further
than my own convenience
and comfort in the mongolian countryside
i felt a true form of freedom
and every time i came back to the city i
looked for ways to live more minimally
i digitalized all of my company's paper
procedures
what once took 20 packs of a4 paper
now takes just one i downsized my
apartment
reduced my carbon footprint and picked
up a habit to rethink my actions like
purchasing choosing transportation and
many other lifestyle choices
at home and work and most importantly
i stopped working on fast-moving
consumer goods marketing projects
and now work with organizations that
promote sustainability
but by far the biggest
change is that i've started to see
development with fresh
eyes in cities
living in traditional juiced as a nomad
and having less
is often interpreted as a sign of
poverty
not just abroad but at home in mongolia
too
we think that the end goal for every
developing country
is to become the next tokyo or new york
city with their skyscrapers
big shopping malls and tall roads
communities around the world are
abandoning their traditional lifestyles
in pursuit of material wealth but let's
not forget
the developed countries are the ones
most responsible
for climate change so we have to ask
ourselves
why do we keep on following the same
blueprint
when we know it causes harm to the world
we've all experienced the consequences
of our choices
over the past eight months so doing
right
by mother nature and focusing on
earth-friendly
zero-waste habits is not an option
anymore and who knows the key
ingredients
better than our ancestors the ones who
survived
without the media or technology but with
wisdom alone
as a citizen of mongolia i grew up
hearing
that developing countries are inferior
and i really took it to heart but today
i want to say loud and clear
that i don't see disadvantages from
developing countries anymore
on the contrary i see countries that
have the biggest
opportunity to do things in the right
way
countries that can define their own kind
of development
and have the most advantage to build a
better
and safer environment for everyone what
worked for our ancestors for thousands
of years
can work for us now and in the future
when combined with the latest
innovations
after all we're all guests in this world
so let's do right by the earth and each
other
just like the ancient mongolian nomads
did
thank you
[Music]